I can't bear base camp a base and I got
people tell us it's your boy I was like
how bad well I guess we're gonna do a
little quest site we're just gonna be
like a contract let's just you know just
keep it light let's just keep it simple
let's keep it free you know like all
about like keeping it free I just got
her here okay so we're just going to man
chase Nets noticeboard the place is
disgusting
let's just try it New Jersey yeah it's
like Bank buy drinks folks hear it it's
missing wife good people take petty and
here my play I love Hannah she's missing
a few days ago she wanted that Watson
has on yet returned oh my god I'm near
at my wits with work and will pay any
price to the man who brings her back to
me
or at least tell me where to look for
her gallon the hunter from black bear
what can I think that they're okay
go ask quest
right or is this a quest difficulty
now suggest love okay um well that's
irking quest here we go it's just a
level seven man I know I tell ya I'm for
this yeah let's do it anyway in less
than half of that but you know let's
just do it anyway if I got a chance that
that [ __ ] out that way gotta change that
if I got that like what are you gonna
head down you know can i buy white oh
man Sam probably I gotta go for this
I'll take ten you owe these people down
here just drink up
Masek was that always on that map yeah
okay I really like the one feature hold
a night just like files to bat now
there's not a quitter this left side
okay all right analog of advice holy
smokes
oh just like fight animal down all right
level anyway now nobody knows that that
guy now all right really scare the hell
out of them okay that's gonna find this
nail any guy I know is like 10 years
away I got time for this yeah no I got
five says that Bay and I like and then
like everything thanks forever here
[Applause]
okay stop going stop going this is
taking pennies anyway how's that one
down today I hope everyone's having a
good day you know because some people
aren't having the best thing not me my
dad was great I'm dressed talking I'm at
like Pepa janaroman you know especially
paid ball in the middle was like a ball
bar you know I bet they're never having
a good day people with that Wi-Fi but
they're not having a good day in there
you know hey thank I'll there the
freaking you ain't gone Las Vegas hey
what's going on I said take it's a lot
okay this is here now I play oh yeah
let's just do this app app maybe we
shouldn't do this maybe we should do
this hey you get out this thing cut up
cut up cut up gotta bop
let's finish this fall
nah man how am I gonna die out here I
guess I died maybe I'm not good enough
for this level yet all right that Sam
maybe I'm gonna get a lot better at this
game nobody really knows
ya know know about it really knows ah
yes nobody says I you know so that way
nobody's barred let's just make this
game a lot easier game PI or is it
difficulty just the story that's what
I'm talkin about baby that's what I'm
here for you know just a story you know
I don't really want to step on anyone's
toes you know you know I'm not here like
Russell honey fathers you know man where
am I like 10 miles away
now were just so angry
I'm so far away from my objective I
should really should have fast travel or
something
okay nose up here get out of my way yeah
all right why I don't think out there
here hey guys that's fine you know I
really don't know if I'm going our way
yeah okay let me say about Cole a
schmuck how like an LA oh my god it just
came like a thousand times easier like
what the heck yeah I'm so cool I'm so
cool
they're like we're really cool then we
take all is that cool stuff
I deserve it just a really good like at
this game like I'm so good at this game
oh my god is so good at this game you
know I'll just take it out you know like
I got is there anything like a really
got here yeah give me all that time just
give it all to my Anna my ABS that got
okay let's just mad at it real quick and
we'll get we'll get back to the main
show on a red you know where's my horse
a how about I can see my horse literally
walking around the map worked really
done over there yeah you can I get some
grasses but I
yeah I got that crap crap
I like I've stocked all right you're a
stock
how about it now that's lower aren't you
saying that now we got like nine if it's
a go
ky let it yeah looking for a hunter
named Nealon found it what do you want
yeah why passing hear about your notice
I'm a Witcher when do you last see your
wife days pass for Dawn on my way out to
hunt moose you were asleep we come back
she's cheating are near mani just hang
on yeah maybe she went to the
neighboring village forgot to tell you
no my sister were never gone missing
mm-hmm how that aster I'm the village
nun saw a boat that's granny told her
Timon again not to wander off on her own
she never listened I must have some men
focused scour the woods
oh look in the woods you might have
missed something ask around say that she
have any friends haze that keeps
yourself mostly watches the blacksmith's
Germans Italians and in the village
Glenna the butcher's for your corner
that's her best thanks I'll try to find
her
but no promises I never promised girls
have that habit I never find them I did
early and I got neck at scars his
neighbor hey get out of here
no let's say here okay hello go ahead
Glen out chill out his ass Glenna wanted
to talk to you about Hannah here you
were friendly
I gotta fall oh she seems strange lately
any idea where she might have gone
strange no a cheerful soul always if I'm
to judge it's the Wolves got her been
howl in the nights through lately even
the Barons men are fee no I got those
vows
Hannah must have gone to the wood to
gather mushrooms maybe straight to deep
and the howlers got her she's bad about
wash Hank actually likes our eyes wife
watch not Karen's might have called in
the butcher and we lived in the shade of
novigrad now this beautiful now he deals
in carrion I can I mean I can't make out
the trail watching this he sang this is
beautiful so buying something now
get out here thanks farewell okay what's
the next neighboring oh let's say who's
this guy sitting here he must have seen
a child Wow
my dad used to make swords like yours
can I touch it
it's sharp better not need to talk to
your father
my Forge swords once now it's size a
nose for good arms you'll need to go to
novigrad wanted to ask you about hannah
heard she looked after your children
no that's why I'm here do you maybe tell
you where she was going or anything else
she said turn it's healthy and we are
eaten Hey I swear to the forest with
another lady
it was dawn almost I'd gone out so I
wouldn't wake the palate the forest
she's done for why a huge pack roams the
area none from the village dares go in
the forest Neelam's only one not afeard
but then he's a hunter jezus did you get
a good look at the other woman know who
it was
no she eats in front of aunt Hannah I
couldn't see
mmm-hmm Thanks yeah well all the pieces
are coming together other pieces are
coming together you know like you know
just a little bit more and I'll be able
to close this case but honestly like
there's a lot of pieces already and
they're all coming together watch a
parent's card oh wait they on their way
now why would spin at me I'm just trying
to solve this case I donate I won't
spitting at me huh hedonic hey how does
that chickens
so that's Hannah jump over that's
awfully that's years of practice though
African parts this place take 10 years
away and let me say real quick who knows
what we're gonna find that guy so you
got a hold on to your breath okay I hope
you're not betting because nobody knows
what we'll find
Oh Jason good yeah yeah yeah hey good
now on that program Witcher Wow
hey are you doing here shouldn't be in
the forest alone I came to tell you you
need love Hannah
she'd have returned long past where she
alive I'll pay you twice Neal ins
pledged just tell the man his Hannah's
dead
nah don't want to know what happened to
her I have no illusions which earth in
Velen you're gone as long as she's been
you don't come back
Hannah's dead for certain Nealon ought
to accept his loss move on with his life
nah sorry not in the habit of leaving
jobs undone folks make true about you
witcher's you're heartless beasts yeah
better get laddie
I need to find out what happened to her
uh-huh sorry mr. dairy no man did this
let's bet the corpse right I want my
cuts made with long claws flesh torn
clear off but what this is getting
interesting just share we're off you're
gonna freak out where wife isn't Jake
get thing I'm a Witcher
okay I'm just looking around
is that a bush I'm like I hate that
because I well that's my right claw
marks deep and I said Dave huh
mmm-hmm no man I rotate miss there's
supper Nelson illustrating interesting
yeah it's not that I just egg way that's
all right you know must be a hell of a
rotting corpse torn to pieces it had it
all around werewolves no doubt about it
gotta be careful
find the werewolf's layer using my which
or sets up blood and Paul marks wonder
where they lead
[ __ ] climbs a tree I can't get up there
maybe find something else on the ground
all right
and they my wire off sign here I'm
looking for our wire offs and there were
to post my Twitter sounds like I think
it's not really that great like I feel
like I'm just walking around here what
is that
should i father's background sir
feeling kind of already can I let that
days
it's over here
when I say something like I'm blind
sight
[ __ ] climbs a tree I can't get up there
maybe find something else on the ground
I'm lucky and I don't say anything else
I like what is that tuft of fur whatever
lost it hasn't bathed in a while uh okay
that right a cow
am I gonna get beat up I kept following
this I don't really want to get made up
man's clothes shred it but no sign of
blood who rips their own clothes off
leaves them in the woods around that job
what is that
looks like a hunter's quarters
my god
oh my god no it's wonder who's
Hannah's lemon
you know so she is she's in love with
the whatchamacallit
carick right
in there can i a second e in here mm-hmm
let's see what that crossbows like that
that you get some good snap here what
he's tired of it he's out of a sword
still a lot better thank I can't save
that
I think I like all the stuff to get
yeah the worst games out there I guess
right find the world with that I think
it's the world with them now it's
probably Neath it well I'm so smart
I had this same thing I read that gets
about the same and I guess how so let's
get some fun in this joint huh
tonic sank
okay rub my eyeball okay says your
eyeball Xena
okay let's go oh that's cool I'm so cool
I'm gonna get paid up oh I'm finding and
dumped on she can't get up get up get up
get up get up cut up cut up that's he's
so sick hey there's a quiz now
angry me to talk it's like Anthropy can
afflict anyone but it is a curse so
sorry but I have to you don't understand
love him he was near to be in mind too
you came along oh yeah right have a
moment not till I find out what's going
on here I love him
always have did you shut myself in here
to wait out the change I knew and I
didn't mind but you chose Hannah I
wanted her to see you I wanted her to
fear you know we could be together not
knowing it was the reason we had the
taste of blood in me I can only do I
don't kill you willingly first time for
that and fun
you won't kill anyone ever again no get
out of here before I change my mind I
paid ahem map run this time I'm gonna
paint him up cut yeah well that's
perfect super strong actually I feel
like this guy's actually like stronger
than I am
sorry it had to end this way
no what is that right here and that
might not hide out
[Music]
wow that was so messed up
well anyway no I guess you want to see
what's in that treasure trance tell ya
how shy yeah I guess you can see it as I
have to say
that clamp here now that yes can I kill
her
yes I can alright nice yeah let's hear
Brian Kelly hey can i attack this target
yeah well alright that's a happy ending
for everyone I guess anyway thanks for
watching you're watching until next time
guys until next time